What's your favorite way to preserve beets for the winter?
Well, we typically don't preserve our beets.
We grow a lot of beets.
We typically don't preserve beets for the winter because we eat them all.
Because my wife and I both really like beets.
That, in fact, that's one of the last things that we have in our garden.
So your root crops can stay in your garden and tell you, you know,
you can't dig about anymore.
So we still have probably a quarter of our beets in the ground.
So we leave them in the ground and we'll pull them and eat them.
Does get to a point where there's going to be some, you know, deep frost that is going to accumulate it.
We use raised beds for most of our vegetables.
So we end up having to pull them, but we up till this point, we've just eaten them.
Now this year we put in a lot more beets.
So we might preserve them, but root crops can preserve in a root cellar.
So we'll just dry them off and then we'll put them with our potatoes.
That's it.
So we grow a lot of potatoes.
We grow a lot of onions.
There are one of our favorite things to eat.
So we grow a lot of onions, a lot of potatoes, a lot of vegetables.
And I wanted to make a bunch of videos on our garden, because we have enormous garden.
So it's, it's, it's very pretty guarded too.
But we also have a freeze drawing.
So the other thing you can do is cook the beets and then slice them up and freeze dry them if you have a freeze drawer.
Otherwise, you can canned the beets.
Beets are not high in acid.
So you'd have to, I believe you have to pressure cook up.
But that's another way to preserve them.
You can pickle the beets, another way to preserve them.
So Angie shared a couple of blog posts about the hemorrhoids.
So she did find the hemorrhoid blog post.
One treatment is called a sodium root for hemorrhoids.
Make sure you're ready the rife program for hemorrhoids.
And here I give some other, actually, there's a couple different blog posts for hemorrhoids.
So if you just search that at our blog that's on deck, thank you, Angie.
Speaking of gardens, this year was the first year we grew cayenne pepper.
Three years I was never a fan of spicy foods.
I started to grow to like cayenne pepper because of such health benefits of cayenne pepper.
Us two of my sudden laws are really big to hot peppers and hot spices.
So they've kind of gotten me into that.
Well, now I've become kind of a connoisseur of some of the cayenne pepper sauces.
And I've made a lot of my own cayenne pepper sauce, which is really, really good.
I love it too.
It's kind of like reds pepper, some red sauce if you guys ever use that.
By the way, if you don't use that, think about adding that reds brand, R-E-D-S brand is just cayenne pepper.
And maybe onion it, maybe garlic it and vinegar.
That's how I make mine.
So I just boil the cayenne peppers.
I add garlic in a two and some onion in it in vinegar and boil it for 30 minutes.
And then put it through the food processor and grind it out and then blend it up really, really smooth.
And then I put it through a sieve and straight out any of the seeds or anything else that you know stick because I want the sauce to be more liquidy to put it on.
It is phenomenal.
So if you start eating red sauce, it could be fantastic for your body.
cayenne is so good to help your blood system.
Talk about detoxing and helping with viruses and COVID cayenne pepper is a is a fantastic thing.
It's hard to find a good cayenne pepper supplements though.
Making your older just trying to get learning to like hot sauce.
And I would get the reds brand sauce.
And I think it's the clearest.
And then try it.
You know, I hated it for years.
If you try it, cayenne is so, so good for you.
We do have cayenne in some different supplements.
You know, if you can learn to like it on your food, it's even better.
Now I put cayenne or like eggs and hot sauce on everything.
It's just really tasty.